Sema-san, please give me a strawberry dumpling. Thank you for thinking about other parents of it.
Thank you. Thank you. It's
chewy and very delicious.
The inside is very soft and very delicious
. Yes to
mix signal Play Sapix ice cream Chauzo Yes
Pump cups are priced.
Please. Yes Yes ph.
The combination of matcha and milk is very delicious. It's
snow.
I'll come with one Yes, it's 200 yen now. Thank you for the bones. I'm sorry
. The meat is juicy and very delicious.
I got 3 convexes from the strawberries. Yes Yes
.
[Music]
[Music
] Nobody
yeah
[Music] The
hot child is very delicious
Shrimp ni Please use one of the winter voting methods
.
No, double-en's wallet
no Mariga Yes, please
. It's a good match with strawberry because it has a precedent.